hey what is this guys I'm kabhi HD here
and in my last video I talked about how
I carry both an Android phone and an
iPhone and that iPhone mainly for a
couple different apps one of those apps
is snapchat or was snapchat snapchat for
the iPhone can actually look pretty good
I think you can legitimately make some
crispy-looking photos and videos with a
minimal amount of effort in snapchat for
iPhone and I'd be willing to bet most
snapchat users use an iPhone snapchat
for Android is a lot worse as you can
probably tell if you have anything less
than a pixel - which is literally the
best camera on any smartphone you're
gonna have a different time with Android
and you've seen this comparison a lot
for sure it's it's totally different I
mean it still works technically but I
mean everyone pretty much knows snapchat
is terrible on Android phones it looks
like you're recording through a fog like
you're looking through a dirty airplane
window but why
snapchat actually I can tell you why
from an app developers perspective if
you're developing apps for the iPhone
there is only what two three new iPhones
per year they've got teams dedicated to
developing for the iPhone it makes
financial sense it's pretty easy and on
top of that most of their user base uses
these couple of phones so they focus on
that but there are hundreds of different
Android phones with all these different
screen sizes and resolutions and capture
methods the return on investment trying
to develop an optimized version for
every one of these new Android phones
that comes out is super low so they've
made a sort of a decision to scale a
universal app for all of these Android
phones which is actually cool for most
apps but if you actually care about the
quality of it like a camera app might
it's not great the snapchat for Android
app is literally taking a screen grab of
the viewfinder instead of using the
camera to take and actually process a
photo that's why photos and videos in
snapchat for Android are trash you know
how when you're looking through the
viewfinder to take a photo or a video
and it's kind of blurry and it may drop
frames sometimes in the exposure super
inconsistent but once you snap the photo
and it processes it sharpens up and HDR
gets applied and it looks way better
snapchat for iPhone actually talks to
the iPhones camera and uses a process
version
and looks great snapchat for Android
literally just screen grabs the
viewfinder that's not good so I guess to
talk directly to snapchat good on you
for the beginning steps of actually
adopting Google pixels visual core and
starting to make photos and videos look
good on one Android phone but you
actually do need to dedicate yourself to
at least the top half or the top tier of
quality based phones if people are
paying more for a better camera on an
Android phone maybe they want their
snapchats to look good too you should
dedicate yourself just a little more to
supporting those Android users but you
probably won't but honestly the main
gripe I have with the snapchat is as a
content creator which I understand is
not the normal perspective most people
using snapchat especially are just
sharing things one-to-one with their
friends the main Instagram came along
and they're obviously a big platform
with a lot of celebrities and
high-profile users but snapchat skews
really young and they don't have that
quite same audience so they couldn't
just buy snapchat so they just
straight-up copied everything they do
they made Instagram stories and it's
captured the exact same way and it's
viewed the exact same way then I just
built on top of it with things like
live-streaming and polls and super zoom
and even boomerangs and all that stuff
so now it's just a way better platform
in pretty much every way and then on top
of all of that they have discovery which
is a big deal you ever noticed that you
can't find somehow has anyone ever gonna
find my snapchat story if they don't
have my username or my number there's no
discovery feature or any way to find me
you ever notice you have to hear about
celebrity snapchat accounts from
somewhere outside of snapchat but
Instagram has the Explorer page
it features users it has hashtags it has
location tags there's plenty of ways to
find new people on Instagram inside of
Instagram now it's not perfect I still
wish Instagram was actually
chronological and sometimes there's too
many weird ads on your feet it's not
exactly what we want but as a content
creator trying to share your stuff with
more people it's already 10,000 times
better than snapchat for context here's
a little story I didn't use Instagram
stories at all when they first came out
I was actually on snapchat side where it
was like ah that's just a copy and you
know there's Facebook stories and even
YouTube has stories now it almost
running joke that everything's just
copying snapchat and what could be as
good as the original so I've been
working on building up an audience on
snapchat I'd shouted it out on YouTube
and Twitter and and talk to you guys
about following me for behind the scenes
stuff on snapchat so you know 85,000
90,000 95,000 of you were watching each
snapchat story I posted from behind the
scenes and it was worth it then once I
just decided to just try Instagram
stories just on a whim so I just posted
one or two things over there and boom
400,000 people instantly saw it without
me telling anyone about it it's the same
reason we use YouTube as a platform for
sharing our videos we could upload these
same videos to Vimeo or dailymotion or
Facebook but the audience and the
discovery is on YouTube so the discovery
is there and then on top of all this
snapchat just decided to roll out
suddenly this update that has just the
tiniest bit of discovery you know mixes
stories in with regular snapchats now so
they're all in one place but it's
getting trashed by a lot of what I would
call dedicated snapchat users I don't
even have it on any of my devices it's
kind of like a hitched rollout where
some people I know have it other people
don't but it's definitely not getting
received well so I'm pretty sure I'm
gonna stop posting on snapchat stories
I'm just gonna leave snapchat because I
don't see them fully embracing the
discovery of the individually produced
content nearly the same way something
like Instagram would as a platform as a
whole like I'm pretty sure you'll never
find my snapchat story somewhere outside
of my snapchat story maybe I'm too old
I've literally I've had people tell me
I'm too old for snapchat
I'm 24 like it's it's skews super young
I guess this whole behind-the-scenes
video experiment was uh over in a snap
look I think at the end of the day
snapchat is obviously more personal it's
for like if I have a quick photo or a
quick video I want to send someone I'll
use snapchat I'm not gonna use Instagram
for that I just want to send something
to one person or one or two people
Instagram is more this became like a
comparison but Instagram is much more
produced content and discovery of that
content even for regular people like you
might be surprised how many different
selfies people take before they post the
one
on Instagram snapchat totally different
so snapchat you should either stick to
being a completely personal app which I
know seems kind of like a bad business
decision there's less money in that
there's less expansion in that but
that's clearly what your current users
are really into or you go all out with
actual individual discovery and make it
easy for people to discover other people
not just people they know but other
people who make snapchat content make
that easier but until then I'll see you
on Instagram thanks for watching talk to
you the next one peace fun fact the only
Android phone whose snaps actually will
look pretty good or comparable to good
photos on the iPhone is the pixel too
and that's because the pixels visual
core this chip that they've put in this
phone actually talks to snapchat and
whatsapp and Instagram to use a
processed version of the photo instead
of just a screenshot from the viewfinder
snapchat supports it now which is good
but that's the only one so obviously I'm
still gonna be carrying an iPhone